Drowned ex-wives amanda siffred's scariest role since mamma mia and kevin bacon since footloose. Thank you, sir
I have another yeah, I know that wasn't footloose. I just kind of wanted to put it in there
You should have left his blumhouse's latest horror installment. And also what I would have said to myself if I watched this in theaters
I'm kidding. I didn't think it was that bad now
This film is getting really differing reviews with those who like it really liking it and those who don't well beautiful house
Go google some pictures of it, but do not waste your time watching this movie in this video
we're going to break down its cryptic ending and explain what the house is the mysterious staedtler and
Sorry guys, it's just every time there's a movie with kevin bacon in it
That's all I can think about nice
But before we go on be sure to like and subscribe with that bell on to stay updated on my latest horror sci-fi and movie
Breakdowns you should have left is the story of theo
Conroy a retired banker who takes his family on a quick vacation to the welsh countryside
Before his actress wife starts a new job in london. You see where his wife susanna is famous theo is infamous years ago
He was put on trial for the murder of his ex-wife but was deemed innocent
Because he was a big shot banker. His trial was a huge story
so
You know to keep a low profile he ends up marrying a famous actress now the film begins with a hint at the film's
Antagonist a creepy limping man who will come to know as stetler
He comes to visit theo's daughter ella, but as we'll find out this is one of those fake outs where it's all just a dream
The god damn dream in fact theo is plagued by nightmares like this throughout the entire film nightmares
Which show his daughter dead and ex-wife drowning in the bathtub in the beginning?
We see he takes some sort of medication to help with this and notice his reflection in the mirror
The film plays a lot with mirrors and reflections
The reflection will do something different than the person it's reflecting and as stetler says near the end of the film
That's the problem with mirrors
They always show you yourself
Oh, yeah stitler is actually theo
But we'll get into that in a bit theo is unable to face his true
Reflection his true crimes and his guilt eats away at him
The film actually does a pretty good job hinting at this to help rid himself of these nightmares theo writes in a journal he documents
His feelings and listens to a meditation app. If you try to stop your thoughts or prevent them from entering your mind
You will only create conflict when you are trying to
Achieve people nearly four minutes in and the film has already told us what it's really about
Theo's nightmares are the result of him trying to stop something that is causing him built up pressure and anxiety
As we'll find out later
This is him
trying to hide the fact that he actually killed his ex-wife something that he's trying to stop through medication and
Meditation and this leads to one of the greatest ironies of the film
While his actress wife literally makes a living pretending to be other people
Theo two is an actor of sorts living a lie
Pretending that he never killed his wife after all as he says you can't tell what you don't believe
So these two actors and their daughter ella head to the welsh countryside which was actually shot in new jersey
Lol for a much needed vacation and this house is pretty creepy
The color scheme is drab and gray a lot of the rooms feel empty and there are no pictures on the walls
They even took down the pictures as we'll find out later. The pictures will re-emerge as theo finds out
They belong to the souls of those who have perished in the house their first night something strange happens that only we the viewer
Are privy to susanna goes to bed at 10 34 pm while theo goes to turn off the lights in the rest of the house
He discovers this weird polaroid in one of the rooms, which we'll later find out is of stetler aka himself
However, when theo arrives back to the bedroom five hours have passed even though we've only seen him gone for a few minutes
That's because the house has the ability to manipulate time through dreams
It creates this creepy dynamic where we have to question when and if the characters are really dreaming
there's also a fun little easter egg with the book on theo's bedside table since we fell a
Psychological thriller whose protagonist needs to confront her own fears just like theo later on
We see some more books as susannah packs up to leave like the blinds just like the family is to theo's true past
And no one is coming to save us. I think that one's pretty self-explanatory
on a walk in the countryside ella asks
susanna why people hate her dad and susanna opens up about his past and how he was accused of murdering his
Ex-wife this leads to a conflict between the two since theo was the one who wanted to tell ella
This was one of the few things he can actually control in a life where everything seems out of his control in his diary
He vents his frustration stating that he's tired confused
And pissed and that he can't shake this quote dark dark feeling so theo leaves the house to head into the local grocery store
Which if you translate the store name from welsh it reads bread of heaven, and this is no
Coincidence heaven comes up multiple times throughout the film mainly through ella's questioning of what happens when we die
We're all going to be together again
In heaven, it's the grocery store clerk who gives us more insight into this mysterious house
The current house is only four years old
But it was built on another house before that and another and a tower and so on and so forth
It's basically a graveyard of houses built upon one
Another the clerk asks if he's met stitler yet who theo assumes is the owner
This is echoed by the mysterious woman outside the store who asks the same thing
It appears that townsfolk know all about this house and who stitler is they're complicit in its taking of victims
They know that the house takes those who have committed evil deeds
that's why when theo calls the clerk for help near the end of the film the clerk basically hangs up the clerk ends up giving
Theo one of these triangle ruler things which I hope to god never to see again after failing geometry
This is later used by theo when he finds the walls in the house aren't at 90 degree angles
Try the right angles later in the film. He finds out that the length from wall to wall inside
The house is different than wall to wall outside
the house is the house actually changing or is this simply an
Architectural flaw theo comes back home to find someone has written in his journal the line leave
You should leave go now theo will later think this is written by max
Susanna's secret lover of whom she has a burner phone to communicate with but as we'll find out it was actually theo himself
already trapped within the house
But if he's already trapped that begs the question
Are what we seeing simply a loop of his journey that he's been forced to relive this nightmare over and over
again
As penance for his sins the evidence for this is pretty compelling
In the next scene theo ventures down to the secret basement where he finds a polaroid on the ground of him and his daughter
Sleeping in bed this image or scene if you will doesn't happen until the very end of the film yet. He's seeing it now
It's already happened. So theo goes on to confront susanna about her cheating when he finds out
She has a secret second phone they fight and he makes her spend the night away from the house
and of course
This is where things start to go bonkers
The house has the ability to manipulate its rooms what once led to the kitchen now leads to the storage room stuff like that
Theo loses ella who finds stetler this crutch-wielding guy who looks like he just came back from epstein island. Such a lucky daddy
I bet you'd stay with him forever
luckily theo manages to find ella and calls the grocery clerk for help and learns a little more about the house essentially saying that it's
Unexplainable like an ant doesn't know what a cathedral is so too can we not comprehend the powers surrounding this house?
But the clerk does hint that the house is run by the devil the devil builds the tower to collect souls
And god destroys it but the devil just built it up again
This is a metaphor for the house being built and rebuilt the constant battle between god and the devil
This would make stetler the devil theo tries to leave the house and walk into town with ella
But the house brings them back
We see here a shadow looking at them from within the house
Which we'll later learn is theo's trapped soul unable to get away theo and ellis stay the night where theo loses ella once again
Taking him on a journey through time his watch goes haywire
And he sees scenes from the past like them arriving at the house or him and ella trying to walk into town
this leads to his eventual confrontation with stetler stetler is basically theo's
Manifestation of the devil an ugly limping man that has crippled theo emotionally a symbol of his ugly past. He can't forget
That's why when theo beats the crap out of him. He turns into himself
He's finally confronting his reflection one of his ugly past
He watched his wife drown where he could have saved her
but he didn't and this guilt eats away at him stitler's final words to theo before he lets him go with ella are
Then you know what you've gotta do, don't you?
That's why when susannah comes to pick them up the next day theo tells the truth and opens up. I killed her sis
I let her drown. Theo's hell has been living this lie
And now he feels he needs to be punished and this punishment shouldn't affect those
He loves if he tried to stay with susannah and ella the house would just bring them all back. It'll never let me
I'd end up right back here and if you were with me you would too
I belong here in his confession to susannah theo talks about how years of anger built up inside of him
resulting in his decision to let his ex-wife drown and
Keeping it inside
I should have left
Years before
And I hope you caught that line. I should have left
Basically the title of the movie you should have left isn't really about leaving the house
It's about leaving situations that can negatively affect your life and make you do bad things theo should have left his ex-wife
But he didn't theo should have left the house when he got the message in the journal
But he didn't theo now believes he belongs in the house I belong
Right here
Can't run away from a shadow and the use of shadows were
Foreshadowed throughout the film. Oh god the puns like when ella plays with shadow puppets
The mysterious shadow-like figures in the house or how the camera creepily focuses on theo's shadow instead of theo
When he comes back from the store the shadow represents the guilt
He's kept in the dark all these years only revealing itself at the very end of the film
we get this creepy shot of the hallway covered in polaroids of what can only be assumed are its past victims the voiceover of the
Shopkeeper says the house has a way of finding the right people some leave some stay
It's also pretty tongue-in-cheek that the song that plays in the background here is should I stay or should I go now and the film?
Ends on the house becoming available again, but notice who it's listed by stetler looking for his next soul
but one question I want to leave you with is if you think stetler is really the devil, I mean if
I were the devil i'd just try to take all three of the family members forever yet
This character has a motive stetler wants theo to see the heir of his ways to come clean and be honest
He even lets him go so he can do this
Would the devil really do that?
If you rearrange the letters of stitler, you get the words let rest now, maybe that's just a coincidence
but it seems this character wants the souls of these people to finally be at rest and achieve that peace that
Theo's been desperately wanting since the beginning
So I leave it up to you is stitler the devil or something else
I want to hear your thoughts in the comments below
that's it for this video guys, make sure to like and subscribe and for more bad takes be sure to follow me on twitter at
Thinkstoryyt until next time remember daddy loves you very much